first of it first talk in the morning
after a party I hope you're gonna bear
with me in this I'm gonna talk about
attacking modern web technologies and
when I wrote this title I was trolling a
bit the reason for that is that modern
is like a weird word right modern means
probably that it's old and it's so old
that people are actually using it so I
will actually try to not talk about like
the common ways of attacking something
like sequel injection or exercise I'll
try to think about the web application
that has thought about a bunch of things
it's such things as sanitizing your
input maybe moving over your file upload
to a different domain and probably to a
third-party service like a cloud bucket
or or similar so my name is Franz Rosen
to begin with when I write the Swedish
Nena it sounds super cocky and the
reason I did this was I had this profile
picture from way back and I met some
friends outside of Sweden if you know
Sweden it's like this is up north this
is in social Al's like 35 - Celsius and
I showed a couple of friends outside of
Sweden and they were like yeah yeah
you're you're hacking you dress this in
India and I was like no this is how you
survive in Sweden I work as a security
round detective find the tech device
like we're trying to automate a bunch of
security show so we're monitoring your
site we're testing for a bunch of stuff
and working as a security adviser that
means that I need to advise around
security so I need to know about
security so I need to force myself to
extend my knowledge beyond what's
already out there so I'm really trying
to do that and one of the ways I'm doing
it is by researching bugs and using bug
bounty for that there's been some talks
earlier on this event about bug bounties
at least like mentioning it bug bounties
in in short words is basically a company
puts up bounties based basically
money or rewards and they say please
hack us and you go to them and you look
for stuff you basically get a like a
get-out-of-jail-free card but you don't
go to jail at all so and you get money
so it's like it's the reverse Oh
get-out-of-jail-free card
I do a blog on lap start to take fire to
come also around like new ways of
thinking in terms of security shoes and
stuff I also do a bunch of live hacking
events so a bunch of these companies
like hacker 1 which is a marketplace
they put up like a live hacking event so
we basically we get invited to a city
and a company goes there and they say
please hack this company and there was a
big event in Vegas last year and I won
so I want there mvh oh I have like a
boxing belt at home which is awesome we
also competed as teams Sweden in San
Francisco earlier this year and we
crushed Team Belgium so hard like we
were number one they were number two but
we were like twice as good which was
awesome
so I started actually as a developer and
this is the logo of HP and I started as
a PHP developer in 2004 she probably
looks more like this like it's a that's
a it's an evil elephant it's a awesome F
I love this elephant but it's like if
you don't know it too well might stab
you in the back right and I started as a
developer and I was working as a
consultant and I met a couple of friends
and they were doing a lot of security
things back then doing security things
means you were smiling behind your
computer in the office and suddenly that
guy knows all the passwords in the
office that was how he did security but
there was something happening so this is
probably four or five years ago that
PayPal sent at least me an email saying
if you find security issues on PayPal
and tell us about these issues we will
pay you money and if we don't need you
to sign a contract or anything we just
want you to tell us about the bug please
hack us basically and tell us about what
you found and we're gonna pay money and
when I saw this and my friends was doing
this I tried to ask them like what what
are they like what do they want like
what should I look for and they showed
me some tricks and so I started looking
into it and like this is super
interesting and being a developer from
the start I realized that I knew a lot
of these things just I knew the reverse
of it like never trust user inputs that
was like one of the things I I thought
about but I didn't really know how bad
it could actually get so I took a look
at PayPal I registered my account
I made like a business account and a
personal account and I sent some money
between my both accounts and I was able
to like I actually found a way to
trigger a cross-site scripting on PayPal
so I could send you money and you would
read it and they would trigger which was
like a the perfect place of having a XSS
because you could basically trigger them
to send back more money and I sent it to
them back then and I told them like this
is the print screen this is what I did
this is where I put it in I use this
kind of way to send the money and they
came back like a couple of months later
and like hey what's your PayPal account
we want to give you $750 and I'm like
what like PayPal asking me for my PayPal
account to give me money like the haha
that's fake and then like remove it but
that was actually true they wanted to
pay you me money because they identified
it being a risk so when this happened
and I realized this was not a fake email
there were a bunch of companies doing
the same thing so I totally freaked out
I was like okay I'm gonna help all of
them I'm gonna try to find something at
least on all these companies I've never
had that many t-shirts in my life vest
back then because that was basically
what they were sending out so all these
t-shirts not like probably most of them
did not even pay money they just sent
you these t-shirts and this like this
evolved into being like something they
call like a human powered marketplace so
there are a bunch of these companies
hacker one in back crowd trying to get
us bug bounty hunters into their
marketplace so we can help their
customers and their customers can like
send money over to us
so this is like the the evolution of of
this thing where you can actually have a
middleman in between so the cool thing
is like we working with automation we
realized like we can do the same thing
right right so we just okay so all these
researchers as soon as you find issues
that we can automate stuff that is like
not custom to a specific company but
some like general misconfigurations or
easy to spot bugs or like some complex
flows but it's a plug-in that everybody
uses or similar they can give them to us
and we're gonna pay them every time we
find the bug so it's almost like a
royalty thing which is quite cool so the
run down for today is like how did I get
here we're done with that that's awesome
I love a run down we're gonna care like
take off stuff I'm gonna start off small
because you had a rough night yesterday
and with an example of like in real life
case scenario and then I'm gonna move
over to an old technology but I will
approach it in a modern way in terms of
like we can actually use this legacy
things to abuse a properly set up
infrastructure and upload policies the
worst thing ever I know a lot of
companies are like starting to use them
they have a lot of benefits super easy
to do wrong I will try to explain a
bunch of stuff with that also
postmessage classic thing which is like
it has been a for a long time
everybody's using it for all different
reasons nowadays and I will explain a
bit how selected it and how they did
wrong so work sucked debugger I was
going to event in in Coventry in the UK
and they invited me for a Python
conference called Python and before the
Python conference I was like like I know
Python but I I don't know exactly what I
should approach and like I want to talk
with them on their language right so I
approached it in the terms that I want
to look for a framework that a lot of
people uses and I want to see if there's
anything quite obvious that shouldn't be
done and like trying to like approach it
in a very sane way being outside
the Python community so I found the
framework called flask flask was like an
easy to set up web framework for Python
and when I started reading the
documentation I was starting reading
okay what what do flask have and one of
the things it has was work suck debugger
and when I started reading documentation
it said must never be used on production
machines when you read this you think
that a lot of people has done that and
the thing is this wording is pretty
wrong there was a big reason why this
should not be run but on production like
this should be must never be freaking
online ever because the work suck
debugger had a very different component
it added a route to your framework
called console and when you went to
slash console it the UI was pretty basic
it had an input box and when you wrote
something in input box that code was
evaluated in Python so you could
basically go to the slash console and
just write code that the server would
execute on the server ask the user that
runs Python this is called like a remote
code execution they have a scoring
system of vulnerabilities this is 10.0
out of 10.0 and this is per design so
this is like this is very very
convenient if you're running it locally
but it's very very not convenient if
you're running it online and so the
wording here is a bit bad I would say
because when I saw this I was like okay
let's look for it online and the
interesting thing is if you had works
like debugger on it would show up in the
header as works ugh and when I see show
up in the server I mean whenever you
request that a website from this site it
would respond with a response headers
saying hello works ugh is all here if
you want something so I did what
everybody else would do I went to
search engine that looks for metadata
called shodhan and i literally like when
thing like work suck and i was presented
with a bunch of companies this was so
bad i was like this is not really what's
are expecting and before this python
conference but one of the companies that
i actually saw was this so first i see
like there's a huge sequel error like
that's bad in itself it's probably not
an injection or anything it's just that
when this scanner of the show done was
visiting this website it had this
specific error but this also exposed
that the work shock was enabled and the
ssl certificate was very convenient here
because when you look at it you see
there's a company called patreon and I
knew patron from before patron was
basically or it still is a website for
youtubers to get like crowd-sourced
funding so if you're youtuber having
10,000 subscribers and they pay you one
dollar a month you get $10,000 a month
and when I saw this I knew that patreon
had a responsible disclosure policy
meaning I could contact them and tell
them about this issue but when I went to
this website this website didn't respond
to me like that was it was offline which
was a good thing but just to make sure I
took the IP address that it was pointing
to and then I I put like a a loop trying
to ping that IP address so as soon as it
would open on for like port 443 or 80 it
would tell me and send me like like a
say pure push and I waited for a couple
of days and suddenly in the morning I
look at my phone and I have like a say
paper saying like this patreon site is
online again and I went to the website
and I see the exact same error and I go
to slash console and like pee open Who
am I
and it says root
and I was like this is this is yep this
is pretty bad so they had a responsible
disclosure I wrote them I actually wrote
in the wrote in header urgent and remote
code execution due to works like
debugger being enabled on an online
interface you go to slash console just
insert your PHP code and iran-us root
that was everything I could do right I
could potentially go inside it as root
to shut it down but I didn't and I let
them know everything am and then my case
closed
I think it was five days later they send
me a response back oh yeah we know it's
pretty bad we've been thinking about
moving it the dev environments I'm like
what like this is not how you respond to
our remote code execution like without
authorization like I just went to our
web site wrote the Python come on you
should not react like this and not after
five days so I saw this and I'm like
okay hopefully they did a couple of days
later I see on Hacker News that the
crowdfunding site patron has been hacked
and when I saw this I'm like that's
probably the reason if they reacted like
that for for this specific thing that's
is probably the big reason why this
happened and when you read the the
security like security announcement it
said due to the bug environment being
online and I'm like this is the reason
so I sent them an email like hey can you
confirm that this is the case because
you need to understand if this is the
case someone else knows about this thing
of course it was like in the
documentation right but knows about this
thing hacks the bouncer website
extracts their data and put it puts it
online and nobody responded and I looked
at Twitter they are like in the war room
sitting there like what the hell what
the hell we need to like fix the media
we've been hacked so we took the
decision internally at detective I this
must be the reason like this is obvious
they had a remote code execution they
got hacked must be a correlation so we
put up a blog post without actually
having the their confirmation of it just
that the the tiny little signs
that this was actually the thing and we
put out how pigeon got hacked and
explain what the works like the bugger
Wilson what how it is they came after
that and confirmed that this was
actually the case and and said that if
we could be like the scapegoat of this
it's fine you like hopefully other
companies would be getting this fixed
also works ugh fixed this so now you
need like a paint code to get to this
console another company that that
reacted in a different way that was uber
I reported this on a Saturday to them
they actually he was at the gym and like
he ran home that's basically how you
react they also like pay me like five
thousand dollars which was like pretty
nice for uh for uh just this tiny
research for this event and appcache is
something that moving over to that
appcache is something that has been been
on the web in the web browser for a
really long time but and I can explain
what it is basically it's not modern at
all but uh me my friend Matias was
trying to use app cache to attack modern
websites so app cache is basically
application cache that means that you
can go to a website that website can say
please cache these things and as soon as
it does it will take all their URLs you
ask you to cache and save them locally
and that means that as soon as you
unplug your Wi-Fi or you don't really
unplug your Wi-Fi like this side I don't
know how you unplug your Wi-Fi there's
no sign for it but as soon as you do
that it can actually use your fallback
so we can use the files that it was
actually downloading so if you would
install one of these manifests on your
website you would put it in a manifest
attribute on your HTML note that one
will download the app cache install it
in your web browser and it will go
through the cache manifest that looks a
bit like this and this manifest contains
a bunch of URLs that your browser will
request and then you're able to you're
actually able to also provide a fallback
at the fallback is what I mentioned so
as soon as you get like
404 or like a 500 or an error message it
will try to use the fallback instead and
the thing was this is pretty interesting
because me and Matias was looking at
this the last year and there was also
another guy called file descriptor which
is also like he looks for bugs in
browsers and both of us was looking at
this in the same way and I I'm pretty
sure so I'm not gonna take away the
credits from him as well here but but
the thing we looked at and we realized
was that any web site on your domain can
use this manifest and if you point it to
a manifest and say fallback you can
define what paths in the fallback that
should be used in this case there's a
dot there but the dot could actually be
like a front slash and that would mean
everything on this whole domain and if
you combine this and I will try to
explain exactly what happens here but
but remember that the fallback is used
when the content or resource is
inaccessible so the first approach here
to how do we make content inaccessible
the whole attack method here is that if
we can run this have this HTML manifest
on a website we can install an app cache
there the app cache would all would make
sure that every inaccessible file has a
fallback and the fallback is to us
meaning if we can make all the files the
file URLs inaccessible for the user we
can make them trigger the fallback which
we control by installing the manifest to
their to their browser and and give the
data to us so we get the URL that they
actually want to want to request sounds
sounds crazy right but but it it
actually works the reason the first
attack is like how do we make every
content on a domain inaccessible and the
thing is there's something called like a
cookie stuffing or a cookie bump and the
whole idea with it is that you on the
client-side with a JavaScript sets a
very very very very long cookie or a lot
of cookies
so this is like ten thousand of thousand
characters long cookies and when you do
this mostly most of the time if you
request the same domain after this it
will say five hundred this is the real
request header is too large so that's
the first idea we can actually if we
have a XSS on a domain we can actually
do a cookie stuffing and make them not
be able to access the website and the
thing is okay you need an XSS but then
game over right no but we're not
attacking their main website here we're
attacking their sandbox domain their
user content com domain they're at
Amazon AWS domain we can't we're
attacking their sandbox we're attacking
something that is just outside of the
things that they care about but that
contains all the content everybody else
cares about so the bug that we found
that was existing in every browser was
basically that if you would have an HTML
file under a path of a let's say User
Content domain.com which is like not
really the same thing as the main domain
but as soon as you download something
from the main domain you download data
from the sandbox domain it's a very
common and good way of like we don't
want to host content on our like Acme
com so we have Acme User Content com to
isolate the user content from the live
site but basically if I could run XSS on
that and nobody cares about an XSS on
our sandbox domain when I use the
content domain that's like expected
almost if I could run an HTML a website
that I can install a manifest that
manifest would point to a fallback file
and that fallback a file will take the
URL it's on and ping my host with it and
I will say that it would apply to all
the protocols and I will also install
the cookie bombing and the thing was
when I reread the doc specification I
was like because this was not expected
to do and I will show you how it
actually
like on our real website so they said
like manifest can only specify fall
backs that are in the same path as the
manifest itself and that was a very
stupid description because what we could
do was basically to say the manifest is
here but I want to fall back of the on
of the whole domain so even though I
have a user path like user 1 2 3 4 I
could say but to fall back for the whole
domain should be this specific file and
that is allowed during this
specification because this one says the
manifest should be next to the the one
installing the manifest which is which
is this so this was confusing and could
mean the path to default back and that
was what every browser thought and now
you're like what the hell is he talking
about what is this how does this work so
I will try to show you this is actually
a live demo from Dropbox and this was
patched early last year and I will try
to show you so the problem is I can't
really I can't really do it on the
website today because it's not there
anymore so I will tell you briefly
what's happened here
Dropbox had something that that is
called Dropbox User Content and you
could basically host like stupid
websites there but they realized like
okay have an XSS on Dropbox User Content
is pretty bad so we'll try to prevent
that so whenever you went to a HTML
website it will download but they forgot
that XML can be turned into HTML so I
found that you can still like put a
website on Dropbox User Content with an
XML file XML files could install the app
cache so what happened was I made this
public URL when you go to it it will
install the app cache and manifest the
manifest will also run JavaScript
installing the cookie bomb so everything
on Dropbox User Content will be
unavailable for the user and as soon as
you go to the real Dropbox and press
download what happens you get redirected
to the Dropbox User Content which is the
one I'm installed the app cache on and I
get all the URLs you're trying to
download from
from Dropbox so that's I will try to
show you in the flow what's going on
here so this I'm showing the install
installation on manna-fest you can see
the manifest there and you go to it and
it actually installs the manifest and it
says in the console the thing is now if
I go to a URL anywhere I will just alert
them and say I took your URL so going to
the real Dropbox anywhere like two days
later and pressing download my script is
trigger so this is not using a like this
is not a store XSS or anything it's just
I'm installing this old legacy idea and
this is my website showing that I logged
the file that I could download and since
these were like one-time usage only URLs
but due to the fallback there the victim
never used the link so I could just take
the link and download it myself so the
whole bug that I sent to to Dropbox was
basically I could run XML on download
drop drop box you see content as HTML
that's a bad thing I could install a
manifest with an XML which is like of
course it's exactly like HTML so it's
weird but I can stall the manifest from
a path through the root of the website
and any file downloaded from Dropbox
would use default back XML HTML page due
to the cookie bombing which would log
the current URL to my external logging
website and every every secret link
would be leaked to the attacker
they paid $12,000 like that was the cool
thing with this it had no expiration app
cache it's a legacy and I'd like serve
like it's like serviceworkers little
brother or like old father I don't know
but it's like the legacy version of
service workers and app cache did never
expire unless you told it to so you
could basically have this silently
running there for forever until they
like wipe their whole cache or website
cache the cool thing also was that the
above browsers did stuff so they said
like okay Dropbox user content should
not have any more XML
jemelle websites we're gonna remove the
whole functionality of public
directories on Dropbox which was pretty
interesting and they coordinated
together with me and Matias to every
browser to make sure that all the
browsers were mitigated they mitigated
one thing and that was that fallback
cannot be installed on the root of a
domain from a path and if you see that
you can basically think like this okay
this means that this bug is still there
it's just that it's been mitigated to
not break out of a path in the URL and
they're all trying to deprecated app
cache it's probably gonna take a bunch
of more years to do that and Dropbox
actually fixed so they have like random
subdomains for user files which prevents
the whole thing so all the browser's fix
that they paid a bunch of like but like
browsers actually pay bounties as well
which is quite cool this was just our
research coming up out of our out of
nowhere so that was pretty cool but app
cache phones are still possible and the
requirements to attack someone with this
is that you need HTTPS which is like
obvious of course why why not but that's
not a problem and files uploaded needs
to be able to run HTML meaning this
could be a sandbox domain or anywhere
and if you can run HTML on it you can
install a manifest and the files could
be on an isolated sandbox domain meaning
you can someone maybe says we don't care
about an XSS on this domain because this
domain is actually our sandbox domain we
don't care about it but if people are
downloading stuff from the production
website from the sandbox domain and you
can steal that content I think they're
they gonna care absolutely and the
interesting is that the attack you know
need to do is that you need to be in the
same directory as other users so if you
have like a bucket upload thing and you
upload user content to the same path in
that bucket so multiple users content
are in the same directory you're doing
it wrong and this is one of the reasons
why
service workers are appcache piggy bra
okay so the little brother was up here
whatever this relation here okay is like
hard for me so but the service workers
are similar in terms of how to exploit
them but they have the restriction that
you can never install a service worker
if the service worker is in a path so
service workers needs to be installed
from the root of our domain so that
means that if you have a if you're using
an s3 bucket for example to host your
content and your sandboxing it but
everybody can upload upload files to the
root of the bucket so the bucket is
there's no paths in the bucket it's just
user content inside there someone can if
they can upload like arbitrary files
they can install a serviceworker which
is like just as bad you can you can make
like secret requests as the user if it
accesses any of the files you can also
do like a fallback thing and you can
steal the URL so it's just as bad as app
cache but it has a restriction that you
need to be do you need to put content on
the root of the domain and going into
this talking about like bucket uploads
and stuff I want to move into the upload
policies this is a this is a really
really interesting technology the reason
why it's interesting is that if when you
started with web and building a web page
back in the days and you needed a file
upload you basically thought like okay I
will upload a file and I will just keep
it in a directory outside on my
application and hopefully that works
like cross my fingers and then a bunch
of cloud service is starting to offer
you ways to upload files to them and
they had an infinite storage like it was
like just put files there no problem
will solve it and you're like this is
awesome I don't need to change disk or
increase my disk space anymore so you
move to it but the way you moved it to
not build your to not like change your
application too much what's that you got
the file and then you connect it to s3
and moved it over to them that meaning
that instead of taking ten seconds to
get the file it's taking 20 seconds
because you need to send the file away
as
from your site to Westry and this
content providers or like Amazon s3 and
Google cloud they realized like this is
probably a bad thing what if we sign a
policy and or the user that has the
website signs a policy and gives the
policy with the signature to the user
and if the user uploads directly to us
can't we validate the policy then and
just allow the upload to be made
directly to us that means that you can
just upload directly to the to the cloud
service and they're like oh this is an
awesome idea that should work the
problem is so it's actually secure and
faster that's awesome but it's super
easy to do wrong there's so many ways to
actually not do this in a good way so
first of the ways it's like this is how
it looks like to begin with basically
you do a post request to an Amazon AWS
bucket inside the request you have a
policy and you have AWS access key ID
which is like the one that was signing
the the policy and right in the bottom
you can't see it it's like here you have
a signature and the signature is
basically used to make sure that the
whole request is intact so the only
thing that is different is the content
because you can sign the policy with the
content so the policy tries to explain
where the file should be uploaded and
how the properties of the file is so
that means that this policy basically
says you were allowed until the 4th of
March this year you're allowed to upload
to example uploads with a file name that
starts with this prefix the file will be
able to be read read by anybody when
you're done it should redirect redirect
to this domain to this URL the content
type needs to start with nothing and the
content length range of the file that
your uploads needs to be between 0 and 5
- 4 - 8 8 if your content together with
this policy is correct the file will be
uploaded that's how easy it is
the problem is basically every line in
this policy you can make mistakes that
is like not great at all the first thing
that is the thing we mentioned before is
like when you have a key in the policy
and you said it needs to start with
something and you don't have a pass
separator
we can play stuff in in the root folder
I remember what I just mentioned about
service workers in appcache and depend
this depends of course on the other
other mistakes in this one but this is a
first step of actually getting to kind
of claim a bunch of stuff in this bucket
so path separated is one thing that
needs to be there another thing is like
if you have a starch with key and
doesn't contain anything we can replace
anything in the bucket it's quite like
you when you see it you're like of
course why wouldn't you that's the same
thing if you have the same prefix of all
the files of course one person can
override another one's file because it
s3 doesn't care about the file already
being there it will just like okay this
is the new file and replace it
another thing is content-type uses empty
starts with and content-disposition and
this is what i'm mentioning like so if
we have starts with content type and
it's empty you can put of course
whatever content type you want and now
we can like we have Canadian HTML
website we can have like run JavaScript
on it or or whatever but the thing is
that people don't understand is that
even though you have content type uses
starts with and you force it to be an
image JPEG you can actually fool a bunch
of browsers that if you give them an
invalid image type but then like use a
semicolon and give them a proper mime
they will use the proper mind instead so
this one if you have this content type
on a file today in a browser you will
get it back to you as text HTML meaning
that the starts with on the content type
doesn't mean anything it's like whatever
you want
so even though you're specifying the
policy that this kind of makes sense the
mind type needs to be a hundred percent
strict because you can fool the browser
to make stupid assumptions that this
should not be image it should be HTML
instead another way to do this without
having the policies in there is called
Amazon or AWS STS and it's like secret
token service or similar it's no service
token service I think it's weird name
but the thing is with this is you can
generate temporary credentials
client-side which is quite cool it's it
like it's based on I am so you write the
I am role and where you basically write
the I am role sign it with another use
with the access key and then there's
like a AWS STS that you can request to
get service tokens which is following so
it's the basically the exact same thing
as with as with s3 policies but the the
only difference is that you can't see
the policy that it's using ask the user
so client-side you can't see that and
kind of makes sense because that would
like okay ec2 is accessible now I can
access whatever so it's tries to use
like security by obscurity and the whole
way to not to not do it it's like do
never ever use wildcards in if you're
doing one of these roles and using this
client-side way of generating them never
do s3 or ec2 or similar be hundred
percent specific and realize that the
user can generate how much credentials
they want for this specific thing the
whole way it works is that as I said you
point it to a web identity or no you
create a web identity sorry and then you
basically have a web identity token that
you're generating and this is like to
try to hide the policy but in the end
you can sign something that specified
was what role you should use and by
fiddling around with that dance you end
up with having this one in the response
basically access key secret access key
and the session token
so using these we can actually use them
in AWS CLI we can just like use these
tokens we got back and then we can just
play around and see what we got so we
can like oh we have access to our s3
everything and in this case they had s 3
star and ec2 star and we actually found
this on on this life hacking event in
San Francisco for for a big company and
they were like ok this is like you have
everything so we're gonna pay you some
money for it another way to like another
vulnerable flow is that the in this case
it was Google Cloud so there's no
difference between this these two
services in this case basically you
posted the to their own website and said
oh can you please give me a sign URL
please and you give it a file name and a
content type and it would give you back
storage api's com storage like a storage
Google API and it will give you a sign
URL the cool thing was you could just
select whatever file name you wanted and
you could override any file that someone
else had and you can just ask for any
file that you want and you would give it
give it
yeah or they would like give it to you
so you could basically traverse and that
was what I did I could traverse like
invoices and stuff and I showed them
though
I can probably access all your invoices
so they were like okay that's like
everything we got weird invoicing
service so this is this is not great at
all so the whole idea with this is like
your own policy lobby this is like the
worst thing this is like don't learn
anything from this slides I'm gonna show
you now don't learn of course but verse
like don't do this please don't do this
at home goal is to reach the bucket root
like that's the idea the thing is with
these services is that if you can ask
them the website like please give me a
sign URL and they would give you a
signed URL of the root of their bucket
like the first directory in their bucket
you will get the file listing meaning
you could basically see everything that
is in the bucket and then when you see
that even though they're not accessible
by anybody you can ask for a signed URL
for that file so it's like a
more complicated way of doing a file
listing structure in on our website like
they forgot to to remove the file
listing on our on your upload folder
this is exactly the same vulnerability
just that now they're thinking we're
isolated that everything is good we're
using this cloud service so writing your
own policy logic I've seen scary
mistakes and this brings us back to like
the 90s this is path traversal
welcome back path traversal like where
have you been so the whole idea is like
if you ask the website please get me a
signed URL for an image and you said can
you please give me an image for dot dot
slash dot slash dot slash and what
happens is that that one will just try
to normalize the path you gave it and
just yeah yeah here's a here's a signed
URL for the for the bucket and then you
have full read access to every object
and you can also list the files another
example was basically you post to s3 URL
signature but it was actually shaking a
bunch of stuff like what the main you
have and and like how can you like what
you cannot trick us but I was able to
find a bypass so as you see here it
actually points to s3 Amazon AWS slash
slash example better but the thing is
that's exactly the same as the root so
the Brooke bucket is called example
better and I just pointed to that so I
could full read access to every object
and to every every listing another
example like I'm not gonna stop so s3
file and you tell please here's a random
key and here's also an s3 key and I'm
like okay s3 k slash what do you think
about that and he will say oh that's
awesome I'm gonna create that so just
because you used a random key X X 11 I'm
gonna put a URL on secured on
example.com slash files like slash X X
11 and that one is gonna redirect you to
the file called slash so now I have full
read access to every object again this
bucket was crazy though because this was
a company that had one bucket for
everything and I have like after my
research on that bucket I had a two
gigabyte file with
only the file listing it was crazy and
during my research like there was a
bunch of companies that just exposed all
their content for all their users you
could either delete everything modify it
as anything or just download anything
and one of these companies the ones
having the largest pockets they were
like okay here's twenty five thousand
dollars like we like this is basically
game over if this was would get out
there this content and remember this is
a two gigabyte storage file listing like
imagine how much content that is in that
one moving over to post message post
message if you don't know what post
message is it's basically like a very
convenient way for iframes in on a
website or a website opening another
website to talk with each other it kind
of makes sense with the iframe thing
just open a new tab from another browser
getting them to talk with each other I
don't really agree it's a it's an
awesome thing because you can really
exploit that one and I will tell you why
but the whole idea is that you can send
messages between Windows and the
different origins the whole way to use
post message secure is that you make
sure you know who was sending the
message so you need to verify the sender
every time when you have a scenario
where you need to remember to validate
people are gonna forget like that's not
secure by default that's that's insecure
by default so people are gonna miss this
thing and this is what happened all the
time with post message you probably know
what slack is slack has a desktop app
but it also has a really good and
similar to the desktop web app so a lot
of people are using it in the web
browser
this was my attack victory I wanted to
attack someone using the the web app and
slack has a bug bounty so I was thinking
let's do it windows may post message
actually I'm like emphasizing safely
which is not really true but it's more
safe than probably like I don't know
sending fragments or whatever like it's
it's not really safe
I just removed that the whole way that
it works is that you can actually watch
in the browser you can go to elements
and event listeners and you will have a
section called message and you can go
inside there and see all the listeners
of the current window you're in the
whole way it works this is an example
from from a function is that you said
add event listener message point to this
function this function will then as soon
as a message is sent we'll get an event
and this function as you see this was
slacks own post message you can see that
the thing that that receiver of the
message needs to Val
validate is something called origin and
the origin is telling you what domain
it's sent from and looking at this
function we can easily see that it
checks if the data a property exists and
the message type exists and then it's
gonna move move further and then it's
going to make sure that another data
field you sent is matching the call
window which is there when you're gonna
make a call so you see that and like
there's no origin check at all so
basically my website can open slacks web
site and then send the message and I
could control all the commands in this
list so I started looking at that and
like this is super exciting what can I
do I could probably get like something
to steal data the first thing I saw it
like I can send notifications like
that's so boring like you kidding right
to that guy and you will get the same
attack so I was like okay this this
sucks I want something else I want
something more fun so I saw this
functionality and also in the cold the
call function and the call window and I
wonder what that was so I pressed on it
and an open a new window and it was
opening on like if you have a blah blah
dot select or comment open on blah blah
slacked of course last call this one
also had a post message because I went
went through the regular ones and they
were like super boring you could
basically notification was the coolest
thing you could do but looking at this
call window I found that it was using a
quite similar
code but but the difference that it was
checking if the message type was sent to
the call we know not from the call
window but when I started looking at
this I saw that there was a bunch of
like switch cases depending on the
message and I found one that was like
okay message to call window EMS message
and I looked at this function message
received
and I'm like okay that's a lot of things
I can simulate and I started looking at
it and like what this is a lot of things
so this was just a matter of trying to
this what this means is that slack
connects to a socket and when it
connects to a socket it gets a bunch of
messages depending on what's happening
in your team and depending on what's
happening in your team you get different
message types so it has like handlers
for all these message type this means
that if you get like someone changed the
purpose of this channel that this one
catches that and make something specific
for that thing so in in like in the case
of call window the call window could
actually show you like you're in a call
right now you're in a group called you
blah blah blah the thing was I am I
started looking at these functions and
like I need to find something that looks
interesting and I found one called
reconnect reconnect was awesome because
what it did was it take a parameter and
then it would use the reconnect URL and
as I've said slack uses something called
WebSocket and in the WebSocket URL
there's something called a token and if
you know about token token is like the
the precious little combination of your
user password and two if a combined it's
perfect because you can actually do
whatever the user can there's a guy with
a horse so when I saw that I was like I
need to test milk build my own WebSocket
send a message saying please reconnect
to my socket instead I made like a super
easy ratchet I actually like uh nope and
looked for the token parameter wrote
this code to like okay now I'm gonna
point to my socket instead and I'm gonna
steal your token
and I started my WebSocket server and I
sent a message saying please connect to
my domain instead with ports which I'm
using and this WebSocket and please
reconnect to that one and I will get to
token and I was sitting there like no
did not work I was like why doesn't it
just work so I found another function
called goodbye and I was thinking okay
so I probably first need to disconnect
and reconnect so I need to like fiddle
with this so let's do goodbye and then
reconnect and I tried no no work so I
thought to myself let's just stress it I
saw that it was doing stuff it was just
not connecting to my URL so I thought to
myself let's run a bunch of reconnects
but then at the same time run a bunch of
goodbyes simultaneously and I just like
let's make it crazy and just do all
these things at the same time and
suddenly we have a token yes we have a
token the problem was I wanted to attack
more than people that I knew of so if
you know about slack you have like a
team domain so if I want to send a link
to a user and I want him to click on the
link I want to attack them that's it I
want to attack them automatically but I
don't know what team they is they are in
right so I've tried this a lot and I
figure out there is one called my dot
slash which is redirecting you to the
one that you're currently in and the
cool thing was there I wanted to go to
the call window that was the one having
the reconnect and a goodbye but the
problem was as soon as you went to the
call window it would say you found a
glitch and the reason is you need to say
who you want to call no I was trying at
least but you need to specify user ID
that you want to call the problem is I
don't know your user IDs and but there's
a easy trick of that and it's the same
regular pikers regular trick in api's if
you want to look for users look for me
so you take call slash me
is a brilliant idea trying to call
yourself it would redirect you to this
is my land called off me and you will
get you the call window which is magic
so now we can we can combine this we can
redirect the user or make a link this
link would go to slack comm slash call
slash me as soon as that is done that
window will get a bunch of messages it
will get like every second two seconds
it will get a goodbye and every half
second will get to reconnect at the same
time I will start a WebSocket somewhere
else and just wait for a token and we
got it and I was like super happy I
actually sent this report on my birthday
like that's how I spend my birthday's
but it was like happy birthday me called
me and like yeah that was weird
but I sent them a report like this is a
funny weird thing I found like I can
steal your xox s which is like token
slack tokens of of slack and I can
redirect it five hours later this was on
a Friday night also Friday night at my
birthday I'm sitting at home like I
sound like a sad person I'm sorry but
that's the truth right we're nerds
and five hours later they say we pushed
out of fix I looked at the fix and they
had like a verify origin URL it was
sticking and I looked at this and I'm
like this looks pretty smart like they
take the origin from the message put
puts it inside our anchor link and then
check if the hostname matches the
current hostname like that's pretty
smart
like why why couldn't you just compare
two strings why would you need to do
this advanced thing but they wanted to
like they had probably some reason for
it and I'm like great job have an
awesome weekend and the after the
weekend they actually paid like 3000
bucks and I was like this is impressive
five hours patch awesome patch super
nice to work with
I made a blog post and it like blew up
in the media like oh they're free and
the good thing with this like they fixed
it in under five hours so they got a
bunch of positive press like this could
have happened but imagine you see how
awesome slack is and a cool is they are
and then reddit comes and like that's
you can bypass that
I'm like what I've just like blogged
about it scream like slack is awesome
they were doing an awesome thing and
suddenly I just like totally exposed
them being vulnerable to our bypass he's
like yeah if you have a no Laura gene
the string is just no so if you have a
hrf on a website with just a word no
that's on the same domain as it's just a
slash null so I tested and I did the
same thing I did I like on a data URI
and when you send it as I said you get
like HRF null the host name is the same
as your on because it doesn't leave the
website so I get to learn something from
from a Reddit user and I actually went
back to snacking like I'm really sorry
so I'm actually done I'd like to walk
through it's just a bunch of math but it
like we do automation we know that
crowdsourcing is a cool thing with it
modern doesn't mean modern it means
widely used developer and security
awareness is awesome so be for me being
a developer I can just recommend you to
also explore the security field that's
it thank you very much
I don't know how does questions work
here but I don't know if someone has
questions they could scream them or or
come afterwards I think thank you